-You guys, the one-and-onl
Reese Witherspoon
is my guest tonight.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Her new Apple TV+ show
comes out on Friday.
Between that and Halloween, it's
a huge week for Reeses.
-Oh.
-That's right,
Halloween is just two days away,
and NASA says the
Hubble Telescope spotted
a pair of galaxies that look
like a spooky face.
Take a look at this.
Ooh! See that?
They've already come up with a
name for the formation --
Rudy Giuliani.
Well, Halloween is almost here
and people everywhere --
-Hey, Jimmy.
Sorry to interrupt,
but, yes, I'll do it.
-You'll do what?
-The song.
I mean, Halloween is the biggest
weekend of the year for me
You do want to hear my hit song,
"Full-Sized Bars," right?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I've actually --
I've never heard of
that song or you, actually
-Hit the track.
Can you hold this?
♪♪♪♪
-♪♪ Every neighborhood
has got that one cool house
♪♪ That does Halloween right
♪♪ They never give out
raisins or licorice ♪♪
♪♪ And they don't mess wit
fun size ♪♪
♪♪ They give out
full-sized bars ♪♪
♪♪ They give you
a full-sized bar ♪♪
♪♪ Feeling like I went on "Oprah
and she gave me a car ♪♪
♪♪ With your full-sized bars
♪♪ Thanks for the
full-sized bar ♪♪
♪♪ They got the full-sized bars
-You stopped playing
the keyboard.
-♪♪ And I'll make sure no
teenagers ever T.P. your yard
♪♪ 'Cause of full-sized bars
Thank you. Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
This is for you.
-Thank you.
-I'm off to
Madison Square Garden now.
-You're doing
Madison Square Garden?
-No, I have tickets to
Bob Seger.
I'll catch you later.
-Here, take this with you.
-No, that's yours, too.
That's yours.
Good night. Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Eight bars.
-We just let that dude in here
Yeah.
"Full-sized bars."
What is he talking about?
Let's get to some news here.
The big story --
Who was that guy?
I didn't even get his name
-I don't know.
-Let's get to some news.
The big story in Washingto
is -- this morning,
an Army officer gave
first-hand testimony
about Trump's call with Ukraine.
The officer's name is Lieutenant
Colonel Alexander Vindman,
and he's an Iraq War veteran
He has a Purple Heart
and he has a Harvard degree.
Or, as Trump put it,
"Who are you going to believe?
Him or me?"
In his testimony,
Vindman confirmed
the whistleblower's report
and now a lot of people
think the walls
are starting to close in
on Trump.
In response, trump was like,
"How could you do this to me
walls, after all
we've been through?
Come on, walls."
I guess I...
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪ Full-sized bars ♪♪
♪♪ You get a full-sized bars
♪♪ And na-na-na-na, na-na
♪♪ Full-sized bars ♪♪
Pretty good song.
I like it.
I'm starting to like it.
I read that Trump is expected to
headline a Republican fundraiser
at Disney World in December.
Yep, the plan is for Trump
to visit The Hall of Presidents,
switch places with the robot
and let him get impeached.
-Oh.
-That's right.
Trump is going to Disney World
He's even going to go to Epcot
and ask every country for
dirt on Joe Biden.
Trump's going to go from getting
booed at the World Series
to getting booed by Donald Duck.
[ As Donald Duck ] Lock him up
Lock him up!
-That's what he'd say.
-Lock him up!
Lock him up!
-Where's that guy?
Is he still around?
Where's that singer guy?
-I think he's visiting
a full-sized bar right now
-He's left -- Oh, an actual --
-Yeah, an actual full-sized bar.
-Yeah, I smelled a little
whiskey on him or something.
Yeah. Finally, I saw that
Walgreens is opening up
100 Jenny Craig
outlets inside their stores.
That's pretty cruel,
making people walk through
an aisle full of Halloween candy
before going into a Jenny Craig.